hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher as a classroom teacher I think
probably the central challenge that I
faced was when students came into my
room they knew okay we're here for a
mathematics lesson and immediately
especially at the start of the year when
they haven't gotten to know me yet the
emotional walls just go straight up and
people have these very strong sensors in
their mind of what mathematics is and
who they are in regard to that subject
Amaya mathematician or am I not in the
vast majority of students in the vast
majority of adults don't think of
themselves as mathematically minded
which is a huge misconception they have
this this idea that there are some
people who are some people who aren't
and the vast majority of me humans are
not and so for me to challenge that
assumption and not just to be able to
tell them hey no you actually can
achieve mathematically but to tackle
that an emotional level if you want to
say no no it's worth you persevering
through this to you know hit your head
against the wall for a little while and
and struggle through solving a problem
or understanding a concept that that
emotional struggle there's there's no
for me I've found no shortcut to be able
to get across that there's no there's no
strategy there's no activity there's no
one thing that I could do no one
textbook no one approach every student
in my class was different they demanded
a new approach a new relational
connection and that's why the importance
of developing rapport and the
mathematics classroom is so often missed
as you know mathematics has this
reputation for being an unemotional
subject it's sort of it's you know the
phrase cold and calculating has entered
our vernacular to mean you you as a
mathematically minded person purely
logical you don't think in human
emotional terms and I think that's a
misconception that needs to be
challenged that people should come to
this subject and realize it is intensely
emotional it is creative its
collaborative and students don't have
any of those kinds of things popping up
in their mind when they think of
mathematics and changing people's
mindset toward that changing the
cultural view of mathematics I think
that's been the hardest thing but the
most important thing about my work in
the classroom
[Music]